[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're now
in the Experiments tent,
and there are so many
cool things to play with.
Before we get to that-- which is
going to be in just a moment--
I just want to ask Amit what
experiments are all about.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks.
So Experiments are platforms
that we bring out--
websites.
Each one is a kind
of a playground that
invites everybody
to come in and send
in interesting
and playful things
that they're doing
with our technologies.
We have Chrome experiments,
Android experiments web VR
experiments, and AI experiments.
They're all there.
And new platforms will come out.
And we're very excited
about the things
that people are doing with them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And a lot of
them are open source, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
A lot of them are open
source, which is amazing
because experimentation is
a wonderful way for people
to play and discover new
things for themselves.
But when they share
with the community,
then everybody
gets to see what's
possible with AI, what's
possible with web VR.
It's really amazing.
And it's also amazing
for us at Google
to see the surprising
things that sometimes
happen when people
just have fun and play
with these technologies.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
lot of them are built
by people who aren't Googlers.
SPEAKER 1: Oh yeah, absolutely.
I mean, there's a
submit button on there.
And you can just go and send
us the stuff that you're doing,
the garage, the kind of
passion project that you have.
And you'd be surprised how
helpful some of these projects
could be for everybody else.
Essentially we can get to
get inspired, and imagine
new things with
these technologies.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
let's check some of them out.
First off is Quickdraw.
And I'm actually going to play.
Do you want to narrate
for everybody at home what
we're doing?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, absolutely.
So Quickdraw-- oh, thanks.
So you might have actually
played this game at home.
But this is the multiplayer
version of the game.
What's happening here is
a machine learning game.
So you're going
to draw something.
And the machine is
going to try to guess
what it is that you're drawing.
And if the machine can guess
right, you get a point.
Right, so here we go.
We've got Timothy,
Adam, and Nick.
Three two, one, go.
So the machine is going to
tell them something to draw.
In this case, for
example, Timothy
is asked to draw to draw water.
And you can see over there
that he's trying to draw water.
And if the machine can guess,
if the computer vision algorithm
can guess that--
it's actually the
handwriting API.
And it can guess that
he got water right,
then he gets a point.
So Nick just-- think Nick
is killing it over there.
He's drawing a train.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, Adam seems to be
in first place with 14.
After that, we got
Nick Jonas with 12.
And Tim-- there
we go, we're done.
Time's up.
They're [INAUDIBLE]
with you but it's OK--
[INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
the water that got me.
How do you draw water?
I just drew the surface.
SPEAKER 2: That's
the funny thing,
some things are perceived
differently, right?
People think water drops
versus river water, shapes.
And it's different every time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks, guys.
All right, let's go
check out something else.
There's something that makes
music over there, right?
SPEAKER 1: OK, so this
is a really exciting one.
The artist Giorgio Moroder,
who used to be the-- or is,
actually, he is the
King of europop--
created this amazing soundtrack.
And what we've done is we're
using the Computer Vision
API to go and have the phone
identify different items.
And then the phone is
actually narrating itself
as a soundtrack to
the music, telling us
about what it's seeing,
what it thinks it's seeing,
as how it's identifying
these objects.
And that actually becomes
part of the songs.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
SPEAKER 1: I think it's better
to just listen to it, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
let's go check it out.
You guys ready?
All right, which ones
should we do first?
We should go--
PHONE: Ready to [INAUDIBLE]
recognition with me.
Take a picture and I'll
tell you what I see.
Here-- here-- here we go.
On it.
All right.
[GUITAR MUSIC STARTS]
Is that guitar or not?
Got musical instrument
in this spot.
OK, what else?
Yeah-- yeah-- yeah-- yeah--
I'm on it.
Looks like automotive
exterior to me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is really great.
OK.
PHONE: All-- All right.
I'm on it.
I think ceiling
is what we've got.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
a banana, silly.
PHONE: Or maybe not.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
I'll leave this with you guys.
Thank you.
That was really cool.
All right.
Let's try a couple more things.
That was super fun.
So this is satellite imagery?
SPEAKER 1: Yes, this
is satellite imagery.
It was created by an artist,
Zach Lieberman and the DAX
team.
So the idea here
was really simple.
What if you could search the
world using a simple gesture?
Right?
And notice here how it
takes it to different places
all over the world every
time you draw a gesture.
So let's just give it a
shot, let's see where we go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Spain.
SPEAKER 1: So it's
an experiment.
It's just a really
wonderful experience.
Right?
It's not like you'll
be able to like
find your way to
a specific place
by drawing a gesture,
that's not the point.
The point is really-- this
is optimized for a really
joyful and fun experience.
Do you want to try the
other mode as well?
So what it's going to do here is
build this like imaginary city
built around these tiles.
And you start dragging
it a certain direction,
it'll start building a road
by combining all these tiles.
There's about 50,000
of them that the team
has processed using various
algorithms to go and create
this experience.
And this is a Chrome experiment.
You can check it out at
ChromeExperiments.com
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
It's really joyful
and rather pleasant.
SPEAKER 1: It is.
Yeah, it's very
meditative for me.
You know, we've been
standing here and seeing
people playing with it.
And we find ourselves just like
starting-- just like, yeah.
It's mesmerizing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Kind of zone
out on the satellite image.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean,
the world's a big place.
SPEAKER 1: It's a big place.
It gets a little smaller when
you get to travel it this way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think we
have time for one more thing.
What should we check out?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Let's go check out actually
a submission by students--
former student, he's
graduated now-- from Denmark.
And he's created a wonderful
piece using machine learning.
Very unexpected
interesting piece.
SPEAKER 4: So this
is Objectifier
with spacial programming.
And it's a really
cool machine learning
device that takes visual
input, processes it
through TensorFlow, and
ultimately triggers "if this,
then that" statements.
So you can imagine putting
your favorite reading
glasses on would
trigger a reading lamp,
pulling the sheets up at
night, getting into bed
will turn all your lights off.
It can happen on device.
It was built by a developer,
Bjorn, out of Denmark.
And if we had the
proper European adapter,
we could do it all right
within this physical hardware.
There's a Raspberry
Pi 0 in there.
And then it can ultimately
connect to anything
you can plug in for the trigger.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
All right, well, I
was playing with this earlier.
It was very cool.
I was able to hit the
button and do a gesture.
And then like
using that gesture,
we could turn it off or on.
That's awesome.
So you wanted to say one
last thing about Quickdraw.
SPEAKER 1: One last thing.
We're very, very excited
today to announce
that we're releasing, open
sourcing 50 million images.
These are vector drawings
where the actual ordered
draw strokes of images that
people have drawn in Quickdraw.
It's available
now for developers
to go and train their own models
on, which is very exciting.
Researchers can go
in and look at it
and find some
interesting patterns.
And artists can go and do
interesting and weird things,
and submit them back
to us as experiments.
So we're very, very happy to
share this data with the world.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Thank you so much.
And thank you for showing us
around the experiments tent.
SPEAKER 1: Absoutely.
Thanks, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
that was Experiments.
Now, if you want to
see this video again,
or you to see any of the other
videos or recording at the sand
box areas here at
Google I/O 2017,
head on over to g.co/io/guide.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'll
see you at the next one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]